sentir et écouter toujours respecter l'ennemi
une addiction qu'est le basket
où le champion d'Europe au sommet
de sa carrière choisirait-il deux manteaux la pire
équipe d'Europe est la Libye était une
enfance comme les autres depuis combien de temps il
n'était pas là désolé mes chers en seulement  une autre
excuse
ils nous ont envoyé le survivant de l'Holocauste
afin d'oublier le passé vous voulez
entendre que je suis ici pour me venger je suis un
entraîneur de basket c'est ce que je fais c'est
pourquoi je suis ici c'est comme les
autres c'est coincé  dans le passé c'est pourquoi
je vous suggère de partir maintenant si vous
ne pouvez pas dormir il se peut qu'il y ait au mauvais
endroit peut-être que vous devriez rentrer chez
vous ce que vous faites ici cherche une réponse
nous ne sommes pas amis et si vous voulez
parler de quelque chose de personnel c'est en quelque
sorte tout ce que vous essayez d'effacer qui nous sommes et
ce que nous représentons Je ne vais nulle part
ça ne va pas m'arriver une deuxième
fois ici
il y a tout ce que je peux faire Je serais
heureux de vous aider
regarde Headley vers le bas oui si quelque chose
a  il vous est arrivé ici en Allemagne mon
père ce n'était pas un criminel c'était un
soldat qui s'est battu et a saigné pour ce
pays le virus a été réparé pour de l'argent
mais anathan a dit c'est ce dont nous sommes allés parler
parfois vous devez faire des sacrifices
pour les choses que vous aimez  tu as
peur
peur que si tu le fais
alors quoi maintenant je dois venir à Lin